[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
hey everyone its Jonas years so a lot of
you have been saying that you can't do
this workout you can't do that workout
because it requires dumbbells so I'm
going to show you how you can make your
own dumbbells at a really low cost using
some milk bottles water bottles and just
stuff that you can find at home so let's
start by making heavier weights what I
have here are two milk bottles so I'm
going to fill up the entire bottle with
pebbles and this one bottle will weigh
about 3.5 pillars if you want it to be
slightly lighter then fill it up with
water instead which will be about two
kilos and the workout you can do with
the heavy weights are dumbbell rows
squat if you want lighter weights then
choose medium sized bottles you can even
choose smaller bottles as well some of
the workouts you can do a bicep curls
tricep extension reverse fly or side and
front raises
if you want to lift even heavier then
grab a large bag and fill them up with
book what I like to use this back for is
to perform goblet squats to work on my
leg muscles and also try some extensions
to really get rid of the bingo wings
this is a really fun way to challenge
yourself and to progress in your workout
if you want to make it even more fun
grab an old pair of socks fill them up
with pebbles or even rice tie them
around your wrists or ankles and you can
perform body weight cardio exercises
such as sprinter or even add exercises
such as leg raises to push yourself just
that little extra so guys this is a
really cheap and easy way to make your
own dumbbells at home so no excuses make
them and use them when using my workout
with me if you enjoyed this video do
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more workout videos healthy recipes
and also fun and simple DIY ideas of the
best